good afternoon as many of us prepare to
travel home for the holidays we had the
opportunity to see some friends that we
haven't spoken with for quite some time
it's a time for reminiscing and
remembering sitting down and catching up
when we leave our hometowns it's
important to figure out what we should
do on Facebook to catch up nothing it
was fun seeing you guys but we don't
need to pretend like we're gonna stay in
touch on Facebook John I know you're
happy to hear that my parents are doing
well you told me in person there is no
reason for you to tell me again on my
Facebook Wall Hank no I haven't seen
Jake I don't know why you think I'm the
authority on Jake we all graduated and
went to different schools Katie we dated
in high school okay there's no need for
you to pretend that you're happy that I
have a girlfriend also those double
dates you keep posting about they're
never gonna happen but I am happy you
found Mitch though seems like a chill
dude Dave yes anchorman was a funny
movie and I know it was a special moment
for you when we saw for your birthday
but I stopped quoting it like years ago
keep it off my profile Justin yes that
picture of us was cute but I have a
bunch of BFFs I can't just cling on to
that third F for someone I basically
only spent a couple summers away wait
you have another BFF named Justin yeah I
told you that right
Justin Hendrix we were like inseparable
during summer camp oh that was a long
time ago and that's incidentally our
hashtag to raise awareness for who you
went to school with hashtag that was a
long time ago so when your friend from
high school that you used to be really
close with tries to comment on your
Facebook again just kindly remind them
hashtag that was a long time ago thank
you and Happy Holidays and it was good
seeing you though Katie tell me I said
hey